[Musik]
schönen guten abend was ist ihnen der
krieg in der ukraine noch wert alles
weil gegen putin eben auch unsere
freiheit unsere sicherheit unsere werte
verteidigt werden oder nichts mehr weil
unsere wirtschaft abschmiert wenn uns
das gas ausgeht weil sie sich
mittlerweile fragen was geht mich ja
nicht die ukraine an also was ist uns
dieser krieg in der ukraine noch wert
das diskutieren wir hier bei bild mit
marie agnes strack zimmermann fdp der
vorsitzende des verteidigungsausschusses
schönen guten abend michael müller dem
spd außenpolitiker und langjährigen
regierenden bürgermeister von berlin mit
professor jochen krause von der uni kiel
politikwissenschaftler dort am institut
für sicherheitspolitik und mit thomas
faßbender der lange in moskau in
russland gelebt hat und der eine
biografie geschrieben hat über vladimir
putin in allen guten abend frau
strack-zimmermann ohne ständige
waffenlieferungen aus dem westen wäre
der krieg war mittlerweile links zu ende
das ist zu vermuten wladimir putin hat
ja die ukraine überfallen in der annahme
jetzt wird doch kolportiert es hätte
soldaten gegeben die hätten schon die
parade uniform an gehabt weil er
geglaubt hat in einer woche ist man in
kiew die menschen jubeln ihm zu die
gegenwehr der ukraine der soldaten dort
damit hat er nicht gerechnet genauso
wenig wie mit dem zusammenhalt europas
und der nato aber tatsache ist dass ohne
die unterstützung militärischer art des
westens und westen meine ich nicht nur
deutschland sondern in europa
nato-staaten glaube ich wäre die ukraine
noch nicht so weit im kampf um das mal
so auszudrücken wie sie heute ist das
heißt ohne westliche waffenlieferung
wäre heute kein krieg mehr würde heute
möglicherweise nicht mehr gekämpft das
ist ja der vorwurf der gleichermaßen
auch im versailler brach er kriegt das
wäre das weiß man natürlicherweise diese
waffenlieferungen diesen krieg
verlängert haben herr müller die waffen
wurden geliefert damit die ukraine sich
verteidigen kann und das ist auch
richtig und deswegen unterstützen wir
das land so damit sie sich in diesem
freiheitskampf behaupten kann und wenn
es die waffen nicht gegeben hätte ich
teile die meinung dann hätten wir
wahrscheinlich nicht mehr die heutige
situation aber möglicherweise eine
andere sehr schnell ein besetztes land
eine marionettenregierung vielleicht von
putin eingesetzt vielleicht auch
irgendeine form von
guerilla krieg der dann trotzdem
eskaliert und viele opfer fordert also
das hätte nicht zwingend bedeutet dass
wir jetzt ruhe an der stelle hätten und
wenn dann wäre es eine trügerische eine
schwer erkaufte ruhe mit viel leid
verbunden aber das ist der vorwurf diese
woche wieder gemacht wird von einigen
prominenten in einem aufruf in der zeit
dass diese waffenlieferungen diesen
krieg unnötig wie sie schreiben wie zum
beispiel jakob augstein fragt er
schreibt unnötig verlängert hätten man
kämpft dann nicht mehr für eine
sinnvolle sache sagt er und dieser
aufruf der sagt 'mensch waffenstillstand
um jeden preis wir machen das nur immer
länger und immer länger haben diese
promis recht der sie nennen sich ja
nicht promis sie nennen sich ja
intellektuelle das ist ja viel schlimmer
dass er augstein eine solche bemerkung
macht er wisse nicht wofür die ukraine
kämpft finde ich erschüttern man kann
immer dinge unterschiedlich sehen musste
auch sachlich darüber diskutieren aber
einem land was überfallen wo da wo es um
die integrität der grenzen gibt übrigens
ist die un 147 gegründet worden damit so
etwas nie eben nicht mehr passiert werte
basierte politik wo menschen umgebracht
werden wo kinderkrankenhäuser
bombardiert werden und all die
dramatischen dinge von denen wir wissen
wer das nicht versteht oder dass ich da
die ukraine wert da kann ich nur sagen
da sollte man mit dem intellekt doch
vielleicht noch mal neu anfangen erfasst
wenn teilen sie das frau strack
zimmermann hat sogar getwittert das
wirkt wie auch sie wie satire wenn ich
sie da richtig zitieren teilen sie das
so der text der text dieses brief ist
wirkt auf mich jetzt nicht wie satie und
auch nicht wie so intellektuell ich
verstehe herrn aufstand auch nicht in in
dem text dieses briefes als jemand der
nicht begreift worum es hier eigentlich
geht wenn man muss vorausschicken dass
die klare verlangt des westens die
eindeutige reaktion der ukraine eine
völlig notwendige folge einer
regelverletzung war die beispiellos war
in den vergangenen 30 jahren in dem was
wir seit dem kalten krieg erlebt haben
das große problem ist dass wir nachdem
diese verlangt bei aufgestellt hat
nachdem russland seine taktik ja zwei
drei mal auf seine krieg ziele geändert
hat nachdem wir jetzt in einen
stellungskrieg hineinlaufen die große
frage ist jetzt ob wir einfach auf der
gewählten linie waffen waffen waffen
liefern ja weiter marschieren wie lange
mit welchem ziel im hintergrund im
hinterkopf oder ob wir nicht und da
glaube ich gibt dieser brief schon
einiges her der erste ist gab es schon
einen ersten brief
war
völlig richtig dass das war viel zu früh
das war bevor er letzten endes auch
genügend tatsachen sowohl politisch als
auch auf dem schlachtfeld getroffen
worden heute haben wir mehr tatsachen
heute können wir klarer absehen und ich
halte es die zeitpunkt wo jetzt der
brief kommt ich gehöre weit nicht zu den
unterzeichnern also ich bin ja auch kein
promi aber der zeitpunkt gefällt gefällt
mir insofern besser als dass wir jetzt
absehen wir haben möglicherweise die
chance und lange denn war mit waffen zu
tun und gelernt habe war fassbender frau
streckt zimmermann sagt das ist satire
sie nimmt das im grunde nicht ernst
der intellektuelle habe ich habe das
wort sagt er in einem anderen kontext
genutzt wenn sie anstehen der von der
stetig sagt ihr parteifreund ja nein
also ich muss schon sagen es sind
ernsthafte menschen auch kluge menschen
die sich ernsthafte sorgen machen und
das muss man ernst nehmen weil sie
befürchten dass diese situation die wir
haben eskalieren kann dass es egal wo
auch noch mehr opfer fordert und darüber
wollen sie richard david precht auch 100
ingenieure an genauer und darüber zu
reden gibt es auch einen anderen weg
oder vielleicht auch kein sowohl kein
entweder oder sondern ein sowohl als
auch ich sage auch ich finde es richtig
was zu liefern damit die ukraine sich
verteidigen kann ich erwarte aber immer
parallel auch diplomatische bemühungen
und ich bin kein träumer ich weiß dass
man mit putin nicht reden kann und ich
würde dem nie trauen wenn er irgendwas
unterschreibt aber gibt es andere wege
diplomatische wege um das dieses diese
sorge auch aufzugreifen und tatsächlich
um auch möglichst schnell in einen
zustand zu kommen wurde nicht nur die
waffen sprechen qimonda ist eine
rauschhafte dass es einen anderen weg
gibt das ist die spd regierungsfraktion
das ist spd-außenpolitiker müller das
ist der ralf stegner der ja auch ein
gewaltiges wort dort in der spd-fraktion
zu sagen hat die stützen diesen aufrufen
die der aufruf seit dem waffenstillstand
jetzt und das sind alle die damals stand
das sind themen wie frieden zu schaffen
also ich hätte es ja verstehen dass man
nach zufrieden ist und dass man sagt wir
wollen möglichst schnell in frieden
haben durch mal die kritik an diesem
ersten brief an den zweiten ist es ist
völlig unrealistisch ich mal der es gibt
versuche wir haben ja immer wie die
telefonate erlebt von makro mit putin
inzwischen hat man kann also einen
mitschnitt veröffentlicht oder zeigt
dass dieses telefonat völlig sinnlos war
und ich denke mal das andere wird
aussagen es ist vielleicht dann sinnvoll
wenn herr mappus ich mal mut fasst und
sagt ich war wohl adem hier hat dann
krieg ist immer einmal du hast nicht das
geschafft dass sie die erreicht hast und
im grunde können wir jetzt helfen
rauszukommen also wir müssen mit breiter
brust auftreten wenn ich ängstlich hier
rechtlich denn mit breiter brust und
immer ganz klar sagen dieser krieg wo
ein strategischer fehlschlag russlands
russland hat sich völlig verausgabt in
diesem krieg also von den 200.000 man
die dort einmarschiert sind sind heute
vielleicht noch
60 70.000 wenn es hoch kommt sind noch
einsatzbereite rest ist entweder tod
verwundet oder gefangen genommen und das
ist eine verdammt große zahl also
russland hat seine innovationsfähigkeit
wahrheit gehen verloren ist macht nur
noch krieg in diesem kleinen bereich der
größe eines eines deutschen landkreises
aber wollen sich eine stadt nach dahin
nächsten immer aus wie gut das sind also
innerhalb von zehn wochen haben sie
ungefähr 200 quadratkilometer erobert
gleichzeitig haben die ukraine im süden
oder im norden ungefähr die gleiche
menge erobert nur das wird nicht so mit
würde ich so registriert also ich sag
mal man muss da man muss das mal ganz
ganz nüchtern sehen sowohl die russin
als auch die ukraine sind militärisch
fast am ende das ist vielleicht eine
chance aber ich weiß nicht ob das
wirklich eine chance nicht sagen weil
ich so nah und so steht es in dem aufruf
auch von eben diesen prominenten von
diesen selbsternannten intellektuell
dass man dass man diesen krieg nicht
gewinnen
schon dieses sogenannte
selbst habe einmal gesagt servieren da
werden leute diffamiert die sich nach
sorgen machen sie sind nicht die
einzigen sind nicht nur diese 40 oder 50
leute sondern wenn man sich die umfragen
anguckt viele menschen in unserem land
machen sich sorgen aber wieso kriegt das
ist ja das kann man auch ernst nehmen
und deswegen das konzession grad auch
eine dvi gerade auch von einem experten
da ist da hat sich was verändert in den
letzten wochen putin hat seine ziele
nicht erreicht die ukraine sind sehr
stark und da ist vielleicht auch mal
eine chance wo man sagen kann beide
seiten sind in einer situation wo es
nötig haben russische an jene siegen in
dem brief steht drin in dem aufruf steht
drin dass das unrealistisch ist so hatte
ich sie auch gerade verstanden erfasst
man derzeit professor krause das ist
realistisch die russische armee zu
besiegen die ist schon ganz schön runter
gekommen was sagen sie weiß also was ist
denn dann das ziel also es wird solange
wachen geliefert und das wird so lange
gekämpft bis die russische armee besiegt
ist man bisher aus der ukraine hat
erstmal so schon mal wieder was ganz
anderes wir haben was ganz anderes dass
sie aus der ukraine raus ist es ganz
anders als russland besiegen ist etwas
völlig anders hat das mandat gefordert
russland besiegt werden muss was ich
kann mir die russische armee besiegt ist
was völlig er hatte das geschäft so und
darüber muss man auch schon mal reden
was ist das ziel und ich staune darüber
wie wir jetzt anfangen mal wieder die
ziele zu interpretieren eigentlich
interpretiert nur die ukraine nur die
haben das recht zu sagen wie weit es
gehen soll und wie weit es auch nicht
mehr wir müssen ja wissen was
unser ziel dabei ist auch klar wer ist
dann die ukraine in ihren kampf zu
unterstützen wenn sie ihn so auch weiter
für herbei hohen ausgaben und bei
ständigen waffenlieferungen krassen
inflation in deutschland würde ich schon
erwarten dass die regierungsfraktionen
hier sagen was ist eigentlich unser ziel
in diesem konflikt in diesem krieg
können sie definieren was ist dass ihr
uns definierten man muss es ja mal ein
auto russland hat die ukraine überfallen
und ermordet wie eine richtig punkt ich
glaube das ist unzweifelhaft
russland hat die integrität der grenzen
der ukraine damit über bord geworfen das
heißt aus meiner sicht das ziel das die
russische armee sich aus den gebieten in
denen sie sich jetzt völkerrechtswidrig
aufhält zurückzieht einschließlich da
kommen wir sind jetzt
verfolgen wir sind jetzt im moment wir
sind jetzt im februar wieder was war 21
das heißt ich würde so weit gehen zu
sagen das ist der erste schritt will
endlich tut das nicht aber lassen
nämlich die gedanken zu ende führen so
das ist das ziel dass dieser überfall
entsprechend dass die das große
zurückzieht das ist von ganz entfernt
ich bin bei ihnen letztlich hat es nur
die ukraine zu entscheiden fakt ist aber
auch das ist nie und nimmer und deswegen
bin ich da auch so hart bleibe ich nicht
weil ich das so toll finde waffen zu
liefern wirklich nicht wird es mit
wladimir putin auf die problematische
art und weise die immer diese versuche
müssen immer stattfinden genau darauf
zurückzuführen sein hat vor einem jahr
noch ein aufsatz geschrieben dass gerade
die sprecherin von außenminister lavrov
gesagt in zwei jahren ist die ganze
ukraine verschwunden das ziel bleibt mir
putins ist dass die ukraine komplett von
der landkarte verschwindet und deswegen
glaube ich nicht weil ich das schön
finde dass dieser konflikt letztlich nur
militärisch gelöst werden kann noch eine
sache weil ja menschen angst muss man
sehr hellhörig sein habe ich großes
verständnis wenn aber menschen die
intellektuell sich damit beschäftigt
haben oder her auch stein explizit sagt
dass er es nicht verstehen könne den
sinn nicht versteht warum die ukraine
sich werth sorry das haut wirklich dem
fass den boden aus da nützt auch auf das
hat auch nichts mehr mit erklärungen zu
tun das ist eine ignoranz einem volk
gegenüber wo wir über sechs millionen
ist die fähre haase meinung ja nur ganz
gefährlichen die sogar sehr gefährlich
erfasst wenn putin biograf jetzt sagt
frau strack-zimmermann gerade was
protein möglicherweise als nächstes
vorhaben könnte weil er das ja genau so
kommuniziert hat sie haben die
biographien schauen sie in seinen kopf
was wird er machen in den nächsten
wochen in den nächsten monaten wird er
sich zufrieden gebe es zum ost ukraine
hat wird er aufhören wird dass der staat
sein für eine verhandlungslösung oder
holt er sich aber bis zum grund seines
kopfes schaue ich auch nicht ja auch
wenn ich in ziegelstein über den mann
geschrieben aber
11 weiß ich putin ist zum beispiel große
differenz zu hitler er kommt ja leider
oft in so soll dieses populistische
argumente und putin werden nebeneinander
gestellt putin hat keine
langfristige vision von der besessen ist
die hat dann nie gehabt
wiederherstellung der sowjetunion auch
nicht die vernichtung der ukrainisch
kennen artikel aus dem juli letzten
jahres sehr sehr gut im detail auch im
russischen analysiert putin ist und
deswegen haben angelsachsen sehr frisch
und dieses urteil gefällt er spielt sehr
gut mit schlechtem blatt blut in ist ein
meister der der stadt des strategischen
opportunismus er passt seine ziele immer
seinen möglichkeiten an und er macht
fehler dabei und diese fehler immer das
habe ich auch in meiner biografie
analysiert mit der ukraine zu tun einer
der der größte fehler war wahrscheinlich
seine möglichkeiten am 24 februar so
miserabel falsch einzuschätzen aus
welchen gründen auch immer dass er in
diesen schlamassel geraten ist den er
jetzt will aber er hat seither schon
gezeigt dass er eben seine seine
möglichkeiten seine ziele seine
möglichkeiten anzupassen weiss und das
wird er auch weiterhin tun
die armee ist mittlerweile
runtergekommen frau statt immer man
formuliert über ein bisschen ein
bisschen ähnlich ist nur die bilder die
im moment um die welt gehen zeigen das
gegenteil eine stadt nach der neuen es
fehlt an da bin ich näher bayern krause
kommen sie nicht frau strack zimmermann
jetzt eine extreme erklärungsnot in den
nächsten wochen dass sie beweisen müssen
dass diese waffen liefern auch die
deutschen die auf geringem niveau
stattgefunden haben die internationalen
waffenlieferungen überhaupt was bringen
also inzwischen hat deutschland nach
langer diskussion nicht nur geringen
niveau beigetragen sondern ordentlich
dazu beigetragen beispiel panzerhaubitze
wo jetzt auch noch weitere geliefert
werden die sehr sehr wirkungsvoll sind
das wird uns auch aus der ukraine
bestätigt und das ist ein kampf der
artillerie die mit artillerie
beantwortet wird und zwar auf eine
längere distanz wir gehen weiter und
sagen wir können uns auch vorstellen
dass der schützenpanzer marder
eingesetzt wird in der tat wäre man dann
er würde man sich dann näher umgeht dann
eine stadt nach der nächsten verloren
hat das ist das tut sie ja nicht dass
das tut sie ja nicht sondern wir sehen
natürlich die bilder die uns vermittelt
werden wir sind ja nicht tagtäglich da
dass die städte die angegriffen werden
komplett zerstört werden also dieses
diese lust des zerstörers und zwar koste
es was es wolle diese städte
verschwinden gerade die ukraine sein
riesiges land und da ist uns ist es ein
so großes land das natürlich nicht alle
städte verschwinden aber natürlich ist
die mediale aufmerksamkeit das machen
sie ja auch konzentrieren sich natürlich
auf diese dramen der städte wo das eben
der ost ukraine besonders dramatisch ist
diese städte verschwinden gerade aber
die ukraine ist groß und da ist noch
mehr was ist zu verteidigen aber das
land herr krause was im moment verloren
geht jetzt ist es eben dieses lied ernst
was so lange wir so lange umkämpft war
um kesselt war aus der stadt dass der
auch paul ronzheimer so intensiv
berichtet hat und jetzt sehen wir heute
die meldung ist diese stadt gefallen
wieder linie ist die ganze region lohans
mittlerweile an die russische armee
warum halten wir dass da nicht auf wenn
das so wichtig ist wenn uns die ukraine
so felix warum halten wir das dann nicht
auf das können sie das ist eine ganz
einfache antwort auf die russen haben
dort im blick eine solche übermacht an
artillerie die können wir auch nicht
durch mit chili lieferungen brechen aber
die russen verbrauchen pro tag bis zu
50.000 geschütz munition das können sie
auf die dauer nicht aushalten und die
ukraine wissen dass sie haben eine sehr
intelligente taktik das heißt sie lassen
die russen schießen lassen sie kommen
beschießen die infanterie lieder wieder
weg läuft weil die russische infanterie
ziemlich schwach ist sie versuchten zu
taktieren sie versuchen sich
zurückzuziehen wie der unseren zu fassen
also das ist sozusagen vom militärischen
her gesehen gar nicht mal so dumm dass
die ukraine machen sie versuchen aus dem
was sie haben das beste zu machen und
sie waren relativ erfolgreich gegen
diese walze die seit dem seit mitte
april auf sie zurollen wie gesagt zehn
wochen lang dieser jury walze und erfolg
gerade mal 200 quadratkilometer hat das
ist nicht viel und endlich diese stadt
nach der anderen einen abnutzungskrieg
der die russische armee abnutzt wer oder
uns abnutzt hier in deutschland und zwei
müller was das für eine frage
wir haben uns entschieden und wie ich
finde aus gutem grund die ukraine zu
unterstützen und das kostet uns auch
etwas das und das spüren wir jetzt viele
haben das von anfang an gesagt vielen
experten auch im bundestag in den
ausschüssen aus der regierung heraus
haben gesagt das was auf uns zukommt
wird eine große belastung seien
emotional im übrigen auch wir liefern
waffen in ein kriegsgebiet was wir über
jahre oder jahrzehnte nicht gemacht
haben finanziell
energiepolitisch und diesen punkte
erreichen wir jetzt und spüren ihn aber
wir haben uns bewusst für den weg
entschieden und noch mal ich sage es
nochmal aus gutem grund da nehme ich
nichts zurück das was mir mitunter fehlt
und das finde ich muss man achten auch
bei leuten die briefe schreiben ist wird
trotzdem parallel ein gesprächsangebot
gemacht ein ernsthaftes und auch in
putin ist wie er ist reden schadet da
macht man im service oder zu sein
gehören angeboten von den herrschaften
die den brief des teams darin keine
lösung namens wirklich mit verlaub aber
ein waffenstillstand ist ich glaube ich
glaube
er wird dann glaube ich mir dass sie
sich aus voller überzeugung genauso wie
frau strack-zimmermann dafür entschieden
haben diese unterstützung zu leisten
würde sagen sie verglichen gerade das
leid und die belastung der ukraine mit
dem unsrigen und damit das habe ich
eigentlich okay also ich habe die frage
wird sich nicht stellen im herbst und
das ist eine ganz entscheidende frage
sei dass wir hier einen tisch legen bin
ich froh dass jetzt aber ist stattlich
ich sage nur aus meiner position heraus
aus meiner sicht der dinge dass das
unendliche leiden einbrechen eine kalte
wohnung ist nichts gegen einen krieg ja
ich glaube da brauchen wir in dieser
runde nicht drüber diskutieren aber die
frage wie im herbst auf den tisch kommen
der tat hier stellt sich an der
gastherme an der kalten gestern an der
gastherme wo heute die politik und die
bundesnetzagentur sagt das kann
passieren dass hunderttausende wohnung
in deutschland kalt bleiben das ist was
da hätten wir hier am tisch darüber
gelacht vor einigen monaten hätten
gesagt gar in deutschland keine heizung
mehr das ist sehr witzig und jetzt
stehen wir kurz davor die
bundesnetzagentur warnt zumindest davor
und sagt das ist ein realistisches
szenario erklären sie in kaiserslautern
an der kalten gastherme oder in leipzig
oder im schwarm irgendwo erklären sie
den menschen warum sie dann für die
solidarität für die ukraine sein so also
im nächsten halten das erste mal haben
die reserven und erschließen uns auch
andere energiequellen und wir haben
einen stufenplan wo nicht auf von heute
auf morgen allen menschen und in das
anhört was kann per sondern in einem
stufenplan mit einer priorisierung
würden ja auch erst einmal andere dinge
zurückgefahren und bis es dann wirklich
soweit kommen würde erst die private
oder es gar nicht klar
er sagt es gibt einen stufenplan und
davor menschen im kalten wohnzimmer
sitzen werden zum beispiel die
temperaturen der schwimmbäder gedrosselt
das ist nicht angenehm aber das ist
absurd die schwimmbäder sind schon weiß
ball kleiner bereich die industrie ist
halt ganz wichtig und das versprechen
dass zuerst die industrie komplett
heruntergefahren wird in deutschland und
ich glaube ich niemanden also also
komplett das ist ein realistisches
szenario wie beantworten sie diese frage
an der gastherme frau stock zimmer und
sie werden im herbst begründen müssen
den menschen die dann nämlich gar nicht
mehr von solidarität für die ukraine
sprechen sondern die sagen meine wohnung
ist kalt mir ist meine gastherme mir ist
meine heizung quad wichtiger als die
menschen in der griechen würde mich
bemühen also erstmal sehe ich das nicht
ganz so krass wie sie gerade müller das
gerade entsprechend ausgefüllt ich würde
mich bemühen den menschen die das so so
exemplare sehen zu sagen dieser krieg in
der ukraine richtet sich gegen die
freiheit demokratie und unsere
vorstellung die menschen zusammen leben
und wenn dieser krieg wenn russland
diesen krieg gewinnen diesen krieg
verliert dann wird werden mir putin
unter umständen luft holen weil er sich
erst mal wieder sortieren muss sie sagt
ja gerade wie es der omi das nennen wir
dann wieder friedliche koexistenz wir
kennen das um dann seine armee wieder
aufzubauen und mit ansage irgendwann in
2 35 jahren weiterzumachen und ich würde
mich immer begrünte leuten zu sagen
dieser krieg ist exemplarisch dafür dass
wir heute aus westlicher sicht sagen
müssen bis hierher und nicht weiter es
geht um unsere freiheit demokratie
menschenrechte und es muss schluss sein
zu glauben das ist irgendwo was geht uns
eigentlich alles nichts an gesetzen
kuschelig ermitteln in europa und alles
wird gut und ich glaube der ehrlich
keine wahl war das ist alles nicht
angenehm aber wir sind hier nicht
gewählt worden ein bisschen immer nur
schön ist sondern das sind hochkomplexe
fragen und deswegen ist es auch gut dass
wir hier diskutieren in der regierung
diskutieren über den weg aber dazu
gehört auch eine ehrliche ansage den
menschen gegenüber und ich bin zutiefst
überzeugt dass es viele viele menschen
gibt die sich dieser dramatik wirklich
bewusst sind aber putin legte es doch
genau darauf an auf dieses szenario dass
wir am ende die wahl haben kalte wohnung
oder
unterstützung für die ukraine an
unterstellt wirtschafts dass der
wirtschaft ist es ist ja gar keine gar
keine frage ja der hat ja der ist ja
praktisch schon schon lange vor dem 24
februar hat er angefangen und natürlich
aus russischer sicht da heißt es gut wir
senken den deutschen um 60 prozent oder
80 oder vielleicht bald 100 die
gasversorgung weil der westen hat uns
660 milliarden unseres unserer devisen
schatzes genommen also das ist ein
reisen böse steht fest wir sind im krieg
ja aber von strack zimmermann erlauben
sie mir 11 noch zu ihrem meter szenario
freiheit demokratie ist ihr
intellektuelles herangehen erinnert an
den kampf der freien welt aber damals
auch das des kommunismus gegen
hitler-deutschland vor 1945 der sieg von
dem sie sprechen
dass der impliziert ein moskauer 1945
und das wird es nicht geben mit dem
kleinen wir reden hier über 100 200
kilometer von bass ja was sie als sie
aber es reicht sie wissen doch dass er
weitermachen will sie wissen das ich
angehen gefährdet ist das die baltischen
staaten wenn sie dort sei alles ist
nicht aus schreibt zimmermann es ist
alles nicht ausgeschlossen ich will auch
was anderes hinaus was sie als sieg
definieren
ist nicht realistisch weil sie werden
dieses russland immer vor immer vor der
in der nachbarschaft haben und ich finde
es nicht fair auch gegenüber künftigen
generationen deutscher politiker dann zu
sagen ja dann ist wieder die rede von
friedlicher koexistenz nein so naiv ist
kein deutscher politiker kein westlicher
politiker jedenfalls also keinen den ich
mir wünsche ich will es mal so sagen
aber wir werden nicht nur dieses
russland haben sondern die wahl vor der
wir noch ganz konkret stehen ist
finanzieren wir mit waffen einen
stellungskrieg im don bassum mehr und
mehr und weniger geht es nicht oder
setzen wir was ich an müller verstehe
zumindest parallel alles daran einen
jedenfalls einen waffenstillstand für
mich ist waffen steht ja nicht
friedenslösung friedenslösung ist zur
zeit nicht drin wir können einen wir
können aber
ist eine friedenslösung hätte ich aber
ehrlich rand soll die waffenruhe jetzt
waffenstillstand was heißt es unter das
erst mal nicht mehr gestorben wird sie
sprechen sagt der ukraine herrsche und
erforschen die ostukraine ist das so ein
waffenstillstand ein waffenstillstand
ist keine friedenslösung ein
waffenstillstand ist erst einmal nur der
stillstand der waffen das ist wie 1918
hat man im november ein waffenstillstand
vereinbart und 1919 in versailles die
friedens friedenslösung
nein der ist lassen ihn ausreden also
ich könnte mir vorstellen dass ein
waffenstillstand kommt nicht aufgrund
diplomatische verhandlungen sondern bei
putin sei wir wollen jetzt waffe schäfer
machen er weiß seine kräfte sind
erschöpft er hat jetzt die region
luhansk praktisch erobert und da kann
sagen liebe folgt dann lassen wir haben
jetzt ein punkt erreicht wo die ukraine
die militarisiert ist ein mitgliedstaat
zitiert ist und jetzt erklären da
versteckt sie wird dann natürlich
versuchen erstens um seine kräfte wieder
aufzubauen und drei vier oder fünf
jahren wieder neu zuzuschlagen und zum
zweiten die gebiete zu annektieren die
frage ist wie verhalten wir uns dann im
westen diese ganze debatte über diese
intellektuell gründlich ist mir völlig
völlig egal für mich ist viel wichtiger
wie verhalten wir uns in einem solchen
augenblick ja wohl partie mit einem
solchen vorschlag kommt und ich vermute
das dauert nicht mehr lange da kommt der
vorschlag der aber wie wir zur lenski
verhalten das ist die zweite frau lenski
und beiden haben beide gesagt irgendwann
werden vertragliche lösung eine rolle
spielen die frage ist nicht wie wir uns
beiden ins gesicht verrät wenn es diese
chance konnte ford genau über diesen
punkt war ein wolf was das mit unserer
volkswirtschaft macht hören ganz kurze
pause und sind gleich zurück hier in
dieser runde
zurück bei bild die richtigen fragen
waffenstillstand jetzt was würde das
eigentlich bedeuten dass diskutieren wir
hier weiter in dieser runde würde das
auch unsere inflation wieder stoppen
würde das wieder energie sicherheit in
deutschland bringt thomas faßbender
würde das aber auch bedeuten putin
biograf dass wir die ukraine den teil in
der ost ukraine einfach herschenken für
mich so sagen ein waffenstillstand ist
deshalb keine auf keinen fall auf keinen
fall wir müssen gleichzeitig zwei ziele
erreichen das eine ist ein moralisch
gefärbtes nämlich vermeiden dass
menschen leben tagtäglich zu opfern
kommen auch die russischen soldaten die
das sterben kämpfen dann nicht
freiwillig ja die kämpfen genauso
unfreiwillig wie wie die wie die
ukrainische soldaten das zweite ziel ist
daneben wir müssen die negativen
auswirkungen des krieges auf die ganze
weltwirtschaft wir müssen dafür sorgen
dass aus odessa wieder war das aus
odessa weizen rauskommen kann ja das
wird so lange nicht geschehen wie wie
die ukraine aus ihrer sicht guten
gründen den er hoffentlich and minen ja
das sind die konkreten schritte die
angegangen werden müssen jenseits des
themas waffenlieferungen liefert sie
waffen weiterhin aber wir müssen
parallel aber das tun der initiativen
aber das ist ja das tun wir ja dann lege
ich auch gesteigert werden will hat es
vorhin gesagt dass wir natürlich
humanitäre hilfe thema überhaupt zu
verhindern dass putin diese welt ins
unglück stürzen
unvorstellbar viele millionen menschen
von der hungersnot bedroht sind das
macht er ja auch um den migrationsdruck
auf europa zu erhöhen wir kennen ja
diese spiele diese diese unerträgliche
kalten die er da auf den auf den markt
wirft also letztlich das tun wir ja
diese humanitäre hilfe wirtschaftliche
hilfe wir beschäftigen uns auch heute
mit dem wieder auf bei der ukraine und
eben auch mit waffenlieferung nur das
thema waffen ist das
emotional ist hoch emotionales und
deswegen immer in den vordergrund kommt
eben das ist laufen parallel sehr sehr
viele dinge dass auch richtig so und
trotzdem nochmal auf diesen brief
zurückkommen ich halte es wenn man nicht
eine konkrete lösung anbietet dieses
sagen es muss jetzt mal schluss sein und
für was kämpfen die überhaupt das finde
ich persönlich ich persönlich
unerträglich auch diese diplomatischen
bemühungen laufen die auch weil das ist
ja der vorwurf austeilen
putin werden sie doch an der börse kann
oder saß stundenlang wirklich große
resperger und schäuble laden mit ihm am
tisch
es waren ja gespräche ohne die sind ja
alle man würde im jargon sagen wirklich
über den tisch gezogen worden aber
diesen langen also kann man mit dem
nicht mehr reden jetzt aussieht im
moment er hat seine glaubwürdigkeit
völlig verloren sagte gar keine frage es
ist ich sehe uns aber trotzdem an meinem
diplom addieren sich trotzdem an einem
wendepunkt hier wir haben jetzt eine
situation eines sale mails erreicht mehr
oder weniger es werden eben keine großen
städte da die haben ja auch noch ein
ganz kleinen kessel eingenommen nicht
den großen kessel von dann jetzt das
steht ja vom vom donnerstag steht ja
alles noch offen die ukraine werfen
zurzeit die idee einer gegenoffensive
diesem monat oder im nächsten monat
rainha das szenario geht der horizont
ist im moment der herbst wenn wir im
herbst einerseits die negativen
ökonomischen folgen von sanktionen
preissteigerungen zu spüren bekommen und
gleichzeitig sehen dass wir mit all
diesen schönen waffen nur ein
stellungskrieg ja wie im guten alten
erster weltkrieg ja finanzieren am leben
erhalten dann wird auf beiden seiten
eine größere bereitschaft da sein dann
müssen wir bereit stehen auch als auch
als vermittler auch als mit mit
diplomatischen initiativen auch so rosa
haben und dann ist der schalker passen
also dass wir dann eben teile der
ukraine her sind wir dann so geschockt
von der inflation die wir mittlerweile
daneben auch zu spüren bekommen dass wir
dann sagen ihre freunde das ist es uns
echt nicht mehr jetzt unterschreibt dass
es wird bestimmt diese tendenz geben und
wenn ich mir den brief anschaue dann
habe ich auch den gefühl dass das nicht
alle so richtig durchdacht worden ist es
sind eben intellektuelle aber dich
unbedingt experten die dias geschrieben
haben aber wie gesagt mein szenario ist
es kommt von russland weißrussland weil
das militär sagt lieber präsident wir
können nicht mehr wann ich weiß jetzt
nicht das kann nächste woche sollen das
kann erst im dezember oder so sagen ja
putin ist jemand der versucht bis zum
letzten die militärs zu
pressen dass irgendwas machen jetzt hat
er wieder entlassen hatte immer noch
zehn wochen nichts gebracht hat also was
er sich gewünscht hatte nur sind die
nächsten generäle daran irgendwann kommt
der punkt sie sagen lieber präsidenten
es geht nicht um dann kommt plötzlich
wieder gas zu uns nein denn wird es
einen waffenstillstand geben so und dann
ist die frage wie reagieren wir darauf
und ich finde wir sollten so darauf
reagieren dass sozusagen die erste
jährige sanktionen werden nicht
reduziert solange russland sich nicht
ganz aus den gebieten zurückzieht und
zwar den gebieten von 1904 2014 und zum
zweiten wir müssten die ukraine weiter
auf damit sie sich wehren kann weil die
russen als nächstes in drei vier jahren
versuchen werden das wieder neu
anzufangen und drittens wir müssen
unsere eigenen nato-partner in
nordeuropa vor russland und was tun wir
haben zwei stunden was soll das hier
dann und dann ja dann wird er
wahrscheinlich
schon das nicht mitmachen aber
irgendwann wird sich die wirtschaftliche
lage russlands deutlich nach unten
entwickeln und irgendwann wird sich in
russland etwas ändern aber wir können
auf eine lange frist die entwicklung
hoffen wir können nicht hoffen dass
innerhalb von 14 tagen mussten sich
zurückziehen aus den ost liegenden kran
längerfristig aber das ist doch das
problem herr krause gleichzeitig wird in
deutschland eben hier der herbst kommt
der winter kommen und die menschen den
wird gesagt ihr seid nicht kriegspartei
in wahrheit sind das aber ja fast
kriegsähnliche zustände wenn man die
deutschen wenn man die deutschland
plötzlich sagt eure wohnung vielleicht
mehr war
sofort in einer weise beschreiben immer
wieder ein szenario das so von heute auf
morgen auch nicht eintreten wird muss
man mal ganz klar sagen dafür gibt es
erstens ja jetzt schon hilfs und
unterstützungskasse finanzielle der
regierung für viele es wird nach
geschafft es wird weitere unterstützung
geben wir haben den stufenplan um mit
unserer vorhandenen energie
weiterzukommen und erschließen uns neue
ressourcen der bundeswirtschaftsminister
reist in der ganzen welt rum um rh
sondern richtige sachen all das heißt
langfrist ja aber sehr bundeskanzler
sagt heute der wand heute vom sozialen
sprengstoff die dgb chefin spricht heute
von einer störung des sozialen friedens
den sie erwartet und da geht es nicht um
herbei reden sondern das ist ein völlig
neuer zustand dass den deutschen gesagt
wird es kann passieren dass ihr nicht
mehr heizen können das ist ein
realistisches szenario
wie gesagt die anderer unterschiedliche
einschätzungen ob und wann und wie und
dass dann eintreten wird und für ein
1000 anderen oder nicht aber ich sage
mal ganz klar glauben sie dass es vor
unserer haustür so ein krieg gibt mit so
viel leid und niemand merkt
und wir haben in unserem land vielleicht
kann man das auch mal sehen zigtausende
menschen die haben jetzt schon opfer
gebracht und haben menschen aufhören so
und galerien haben kinder das wissen
genau direkt hier vorher aus und die
werden auch weil sie ja spüren dass dort
hilfe nötig es werden auch akzeptieren
dass man bei uns auch auswirkungen spürt
dieses jahr die frage ist wie lange man
das so lange man bereit ist zu tragen
gehören einmal was der bundeskanzler
heute gesagt
wenn plötzlich die heiz rechnung um ein
paar hundert euro steigt dann ist das
eine summe die viele nicht wirklich
bewältigen können wer seiner spreng
stadt das ist sozialer sprengstoff
darüber muss man ganz klar ihre worte
finden
fraktion interessanten stellen der frage
sie sagen es ist ja
das passt gar nicht bei allem respekt
gar nicht so so ein wort passt gar nicht
zum wohl ist gleich sagen aber sie sagt
sie mein sozialer sprengstoff und dann
hat das wiederholt das ist eine
interessante journalistischer kniffe der
aufgegangen ist weil ich glaube herr
müller sie kennen die noch besser dass
er das von sich aus so nicht und das
findet sie übertrieben einzahler spiel
schauen sie wir können wir können sie
können in ihrer bild zeitung schreiben
gastwirt aus macht euch zieht euch warm
an es wird alles ganz schrecklich dass
diese szenarien können wir jetzt
definieren sagte habeck gesagt das hat
die bundesnetzagentur diese ich sage
ihnen wir beschäftigen uns damit was
herr müller auch gerade aufgeführt hat
damit dass das nicht passiert trotzdem
muss man menschen sensibilisieren dass
dieser krieg uns etwas angeht und wie
ihr auch merken und schauen sie es gab
so viele krisen auf dieser welt und
deutschland hat sich möglich im herzen
europas gemütliche noch gar nicht und
jetzt legen stock zimmer passiert etwas
natürlich merken wir das also und ich
finde es auch unlauter zusagen macht
euch mal locker er klagt uns nicht da
das ist der punkt und deswegen möchtest
du gerne auf den tisch legen weil mein
eindruck ist auch an der runde dass sie
sich das weiterhin schön und die
unternehmen zunächst sehr dass die
beteiligungshöhe weiter sind wir nämlich
diese diese extrem schwierigen szenarien
für den herbst für den winter längst
voraus planen wir mal ganz konkret ganz
konkret am 11 juli wird trotzdem 1
abgeschickt hat das ist die zehntägige
jährliche inspektion ja mit großen
fragezeichen ob es nach zehn tagen
wieder
angestellt die ids wir haben also den
lackmustest der russischen vertragstreue
noch in diesem monat
also ich gehöre woche ich verstehe ihre
rolle als sie sind abgeordnete
volksvertreter sie haben eine gewisse
verantwortung für ruhe und stabilität in
diesem land aber ich teile auch die
sorgen vieler menschen denn in die drei
monaten kann sich das extrem am strick
zum andern aber ihr habt noch kein
notstromaggregat gekauft aber die
deutschen kaufen sich mit strom ihr
kriegt aber wir haben auch die korona
krise losgehen klopapier eingekauft wie
ist nichts mehr da war und das mag jetzt
so sein weil es irgendwo was ihre
zeitung stand kauft euch ein
notstromaggregat
wirkt wie ich finde ernsthaftigkeit
szenarien überlegen völlig richtig macht
diese bundesregierung
und so wird wenn ich das in
anführungszeichen durchgespielt was
könnte im schlechtesten fall gekommen
und was haben wir verantworten
selbstverständlich machen wir uns damit
darum gedanken und überlegen wie kann
man das händel aber ich finde diese
panikmache ganz problematisch ich möchte
den menschen in deutschland keine angst
machen wir sind gewählt worden als
volksvertreterin vertreter dass wir wenn
krisen sind dass wir auch in der lage
sind diese krisen zu meistern
die frage wo es existenziell wird wurde
an den wohlstand rangeht ob ihre
argumente ob unsere argumente
überzeugend sind das wird man nämlich
mit voller anstrengung dann in menschen
den millionen menschen erklären müssen
an der gastherme das ist das thema und
nicht ob sie richtig oder falsch liegen
sondern ob sie dann in dem moment den
menschen vermitteln können dass sie die
argumente auf ihrer seite haben herr
krause da kann man dann sagen unsere
waffenlieferung die westlichen
waffenlieferung die haben entscheidendes
gebracht die haben entscheiden diesen
krieg bei 11 wenn sie den leuten an der
gastherme erklären dass nein dass alle
dürfen nicht mit dem anderen zusammen
bringen wir machten die waffenlieferung
weil die ukraine angegriffen wird und
man letztendlich wenn man sich das
ultimatum von protein anschaut vom
letzten jahr das ist ein ultimatum an
uns gewesen und es hätte auch ganz
anders anfangen kann der krieg erst
gegen die baltischen staaten nicht erst
gegen ukraine also das muss man mal von
einander trennen und ja es kann
verschiedene szenarien gehen aber ich
muss ganz ehrlich sagen wir sind hier
keine energie expertin dann müssen sich
jemand von der energieagentur mitte mit
der von der netzagentur mit dabei haben
oder energieexperte die könnt ihr das
ein bisschen grauer sich schon hier
gehabt und wir haben uns genau diese
expertise geholt werden jetzt die auch
von müller geholt und herr müller ich
habe ihn ja gerade zitiert das waren
eben keine wilden überschriften von uns
was sie gerade gesagt haben vorschlag
zimmermann sondern wir haben uns auf ein
haarweg berufen der von genau diesen
gas-notstand waren die haben uns auch
klaus müller seinen früheren
parteifreund berufen der genau davor
warnt der notstromaggregate er weil es
doch richtig ist dass man den menschen
in deutschland die szenarien vor augen
was könnte passieren aber genauso muss
man ihnen szenarien vor augen führen
dass wir bereit sind zu unternehmen um
das drama nicht hochkochen zu lassen und
auf der anderen seite muss man auch
hintergründe erklärt deswegen und ich
räume ein das ist nicht einfach das
einzubetten so eine so eine thematik
komplett einzubetten das ist nicht
einfach ja aber einfach ist alles nicht
und deswegen ist es unsere aufgabe das
zu erklären aber ich bin nicht bereit in
menschen angst zu machen modernen sie
recht herr müller es gibt genug menschen
die sowieso schon sorge haben da ist
krieg die schrecklichen bilder jeden
morgen sehe ich dass die wollen das
nicht die denken was kommt da auf uns
aber heißen alles halten wir das aus der
kanzler wie gesagt warnt und bei puten
immer eben keine augen nase und
bereicherte er interessant dass der
kanzler dann in dem interview was sie
eingespielt haben nicht gesagt hat da
kommt etwas problematisches oder hinzu
und deshalb beenden wir die
unterstützung für die ukraine hat da
nicht als andere häuser geben man das
doch jetzt das interessante man genau
was wollen sie jetzt hier in der
diskussion von uns hören wir sagen ihnen
sozialer sprengstoff hatte so gut wie
ihr wissen und so gut wie es können
bereiten wir uns auf die nächsten monate
vorhin mit den unterschiedlichsten
schritten und maßnahmen aber es wird
trotzdem wahrscheinlich so sein dass
menschen spüren dass da etwas passiert
um uns herum und das ist auch eine
belastung wird und wir nicht gehören zu
denen die sagen wir werden sollten nicht
nur überwachen reden aber trotzdem sage
ich wir sind auf einem weg wo wir uns
entschieden haben aus guten gründen die
ukraine zu unterstützen und das können
wir nicht beenden weil wir auf einmal
merken dass energie teurer wird für uns
das wird nicht funktionieren dann muss
die politik andere wege finden um den
menschen die das nicht alleine tragen
können zu helfen das ist die kunst der
politik halten sie das szenario für
wahrscheinlich oder das millionen
deutsche leben herr faßbender im herbst
sagen werden in der abwägung ist eben
mir die wohnung die warme wohnung ist
mir das gas aus russland lieber als die
sanktionen die treffen uns mittlerweile
härter als putin ich versuchte so seine
ihre kausalität ist ja absolut
nachvollziehbar auf eine gewisse ihre
auch auf eine gewisse weise hat dass
beides nicht miteinander zu tun aber
schauen halt die reale situation an wenn
jetzt im nächsten monat in den nächsten
acht wochen keine erfolgreiche
ukrainische gegenoffensive geschieht wir
können davon ausgehen dass ich gehe
davon aus dass die russischen das
russische vordringen mehr oder weniger
in dem in dem jetzt im rahmen bleibt
wenn sich das ganze also fest ist ja und
dann kommen die probleme die
ökonomischen probleme von stadt
zimmermann hat ihre fraktion in drei
vier fünf monaten und viel viel
schwierigeren stand weil dann nämlich
die menschen sagen das eine hat mit dem
anderen vielleicht nichts zu tun aber
warum werfen wieder weiterhin monat für
monat woche für woche in einen krieg in
dem sich nichts bewegt wo es doch
zumindest die hoffnung gebe wenn es
diesen krieg nicht gäbe ging es uns
unsere borgmann die besser das muss man
den menschen eben erklärt deswegen kann
man ja nicht seine politik beim baggern
oder sie wollen hinein werfen also muss
man dazu machen wir werden die flaschen
hinein geworfen sondern wir haben eine
diskussion geführt was geliefert wird
was nicht der bundeskanzler hat gb 7 und
jetzt bei dem nato ganz klar zum
ausdruck gebracht und wir begrüßen das
ausdrücklich
er sagte wir werden der ukraine so lange
waffen liefern wie die ukraine ist
benötigt wir diskutieren jetzt über die
art der waffen das kann man alles machen
aber eher distanziert sich eben nicht
davon im gegenteil es war der
bundeskanzler dass jahre dauert glauben
sie dabei schauen sie mal wir machen
politik aus dem jetzt heraus wir werden
dass wir was wir diskutieren in paar
jahren wird über uns gerichtet werden
das meine ich mit großem weg war das
richtig was die bundesrepublik gemacht
hat war das was die bundesregierung
gemacht hat es gibt keine
bundesregierung in diesem land die nach
80 tagen mit einer solchen situation
konfrontiert wurde in der tat und
deswegen entscheiden wir heute
diskutieren wegen ab entscheiden ob das
am langen ende richtig ist dass werden
die entscheidende die geschichtsbücher
einmal befüllen damit unsere
enkelgeneration das versprechen lassen
ist heute allgemein sprechen der ukraine
so lange teile dieses braucht teile ist
ausdrücklich was der bundeskanzler sagt
weil es eben um sehr viel geht und
deswegen muss man das den menschen
erklären und ich bin bayern müller in
diesen fällen müssen wir in der lage
sein denen wo eben jeder 100 euro schein
an ausgaben mehr für energie denen
müssen wir helfen das heißt aber nicht
dass jedem in deutschland das schmerzt
aber denen wo es an die substanz geht
muss geholfen werden
und ich bin auch optimistisch genug dass
wir das auch hinbekommen bei dir ja
bereits seit wochen uns alternativen
anschauen und es ist ja ganz spannend
wenn ich das nicht bin überhaupt keine
energiepolitikerin deswegen bitte kein
weiteres gespräch darüber aber ich wage
ich aus dem fenster zu lehnen die
tatsache dass wir uns mit geprägtem gas
beschäftigen die tatsache dass plötzlich
genehmigungen um diese zu speichern sehr
sehr schnell gehen in wenigen monaten wo
einer sagt also wenn wir das machen das
dauert jahre das zeigt ja dass unter
diesem druck unter dem wir stehen
nämlich dass die bevölkerung nicht
friert unglaublich viel möglich ist das
was wir uns vor einem jahr die übrigens
sehr vieles nicht haben wird man das
über mit geld zu schmieren können
verzeihen sie den begriff aber wenn der
kanzler von sozialem sprengstoff spricht
und sie diejenigen ansprechen die brutal
unter den strom- und gasrechnungen
leiden werden im herbst und im winter
meistens diejenigen die arbeiten gehen
die nicht so viel geld verdienen die
meisten die eine familie haben also ein
bisschen größere wohnung haben wie wir
an darunter leiden glauben sie dass man
das diesen herbst und winter mit geld zu
schmieren kann ich denke ja es ist ja
für viele leute ein finanzielles problem
und finanzielle probleme kann man lösen
indem man denjenigen menschen die
wirklich toller leiten
erleichterung finanzielle erleichterung
gibt machen die ich brauche das nicht
ich komme allein darüber aber es gibt
viele leute und ich glaube dass die
mehrzahl der normalen leute die haben
probleme und da muss man sehen wie man
etwa durch steuersenkungen oder durch
zuschüsse dem menschen hilft über diesen
winter zu kommen denn dieser winter wird
das schwierigste sein danach wird es
besser werden
diese bundesregierung und die vorgehen
jedoch bei corona sehr viel geld in die
hand können wir haben und nach ich meine
wir sind sie noch mit dem corona
also alles zusammen ja aber rein
psychologisch gehen wir heute anders
damit um wurden wurde auch vielen
geholfen neben persönlichen schicksalen
keine frage branche die besonders
betroffen waren auch verwerfungen die
wir heute spüren weil viele ihrem beruf
geändert haben trotzdem haben wir im
vergleich zu internationalen ausland ein
letztlich unglaublich viel hinbekommen
und deswegen würde ich nicht sagen das
erinnert mich so ein bisschen an ich
klebe nicht so mit meiner kohle so es
war noch ein bisschen anders dieses
zitat ja es war ich zwar noch so ich als
gut jeder weiß jetzt wer alt genug ist
also auf alle fälle das natürlich hilft
wenn man menschen
wenn man sie finanziell entlastet ja
natürlich weil es ein finanzielles
problem ist und dann wird in deutschland
nicht das passieren was manche
befürchten dass es dann heißt der
faßbender germany first
alles mögliche schlimme kann passieren
ich möchte aber mal denen ich möchte mal
das augenmerk noch mal eine ganz andere
sichtweise und also immer kurz bei dem
gedanken bleiben weil es gibt diesen
gedanken längst er wird von ihren
kollegen im bundestag kollegen in
anführungsstrichen von der afg längst
ausgesprochen es gibt stimmen lassen sie
uns das einmal reichen ein video das
sind dieser woche mehrere millionen
klicks gemacht hat und schauen sie was
dort mittlerweile längst im umlauf ist
damit müssen wir uns auseinandersetzen
übrigens rechnet die bundesagentur für
arbeit bis ende des jahres mit
746.000 ukraine in hartz4 da ist man
schnell mal bei über 1000 euro jeden
monat und das ist der eigentliche
skandal
bei müttern in rente die drei kinder zur
welt gebracht haben sind es sogar nur 7
151 euro ich finde das ist einfach nur
noch das ist nichts anderes als ein
bedingungsloses grund einkommen für
ukraine das amt zahlt alles davon
könnten die steuerzahler in deutschland
nur träumen dann würde das das stimmen
mit denen wir uns auch außen schlimm
genug dass wir diesen mist sogar noch
ein spiel weil es ist wirklich
eigentlich 14 ja und es ist ein aus
gegeneinander ausspielen von menschen
die hilfe und unterstützung brauchen die
kinderreiche familie braucht genauso
hilfe und unterstützung wie die die
gerade aus einem kriegsgebiet kommen und
sowas spielt man nicht gegeneinander aus
und um das jetzt auch noch komplett zu
machen am meisten ärgert mich dass wir
nicht auch mal darüber reden dass jetzt
schon wäre dieser kriegstage menschen
verhungern sie haben es angesprochen
weil lieferungen nicht ankommen weizen
die frau nicht ankommen es gibt jetzt
schlimmste hungerkatastrophe auf der
welt die überhaupt nicht im blick sind
weil wir auch nachvollziehbar uns
natürlich auch mit dem geschehenen
stetter russische steht in diesem brief
habe dieser aber es muss einmal
einordnen und die habe die stadt zu
leben doch von krisen
superklasse jetzt kommen menschen flucht
super jetzt hungern die ist ja auch egal
wenn die jungen und die leben immer nur
von dem krisen dieser welt und das ist
ekelhaft und widerlich und
wirklich einen solchen mit verlaub
solche aussage ich auch noch zu pflanzen
brasilianers links passiert ist weil das
längst überall im netz ist wahnsinnig da
kein gehör möchte ich dass sie sich
damit auseinandersetzen und argumente
haben weil das ist ihre aufgabe ist das
macht ja gott sei dank mit 85 prozent
der bundestag ist ja ganz ganz klar war
was hast du denn was ich der afg
entgegen entfallen das ist ekelhaft ist
menschen gegeneinander auszuspielen und
dass wir die verdammte pflicht haben
menschen zu helfen die auf der flucht
sind übrigens ist das sehr interessant
schauen sie sich mal an mit denen der
afg ist da gibt es leute wie frau von
storch die durchaus weiß aus ihrer
familiengeschichte was flucht und
vertreibung bedeutet dann wäre ich ja
mal ein bisschen demütig da gibt es eine
menge menschen die das selber erlebt
haben und wissen wie wichtig es ist dass
andere füreinander da sind und ich
schäme mich wirklich dass es solche dass
es solche aussagen gibt weil ganz ganz
ganz tausende millionen von deutschen
helfen den ukrainerinnen uns lange und
machen das wirklich bravourös ist und
dass das muss herausgestellt werden also
ich sehe ich sehe auch wo sie germany
festansprachen ich glaube bei uns ist
gerade mit blick auf die ukraine ja das
germany first potenzial potenzielle
elektrorad das ist durch die hft schon
jetzt weitgehend ausgeschöpft wir dürfen
nicht vergessen dass und da kommt man
natürlich ein anderes kulturelles thema
ja dass die einstellung eines großen
teils der bevölkerung gegenüber gerade
gegenüber den ukrainern durchaus
positiver ist ihre möglichen als mit eu
fremden zuwanderern aus dem süden oder
aus dem aus dem fernen osten ist ist ein
ganz anderes thema mich ich werde mich
aber trotzdem weiterhin frau stark
zimmermann an ihre ja praktisch
unbegrenzten an ihrem unbegrenzten ein
stehen sie am anfang noch mal gesagt die
ukraine bestimmt die kriegsziele wir ja
wir stehen dabei da kommt sofort
automatisch bei mir immer dass krim
thema auf ja werden deutsche werden
werden deutsche wirklich hinter der
ukraine stehen wenn die ukraine sich
möglicherweise unter dem risiko atomarer
gegenwehr seitens der russen die krim
wiederholen will und jetzt springe ich
aber noch im nächsten wieder drin ist 3d
rigs ja weil sie müssen sie diesen
genauso stehen einer nein überhaupt
nicht wenn wenn ihnen ein auto geklaut
wird das hören sie sich wieder verdammt
und die beckers mir gehört ja das
ist ja sagt dass die creme der ukraine
gehör wiederholt die realität wieder
sage ich möchte das taxi ich möchte noch
mal auf was anderes hinaus sie öffnen
den letzten endes einer geradezu zeit
grenzenlosen verlängerung dieses krieges
ton tür wir haben ein auch in dieser
diskussion wir haben einen fast schon
ein tunnelblick auf die ukraine jeder
monat den dieser krieg sich verlängert
für zu anderen konnten konstellationen
in außereuropäischen bei außer
europäischen mächten wir haben die
diskussion was macht die türkei im
windschatten des krieges mit blick auf
noch syrien mit blick auf den iran wir
haben die diskussion wie lange schauen
wachten die chinesen vielleicht auf den
richtigen namen wirtschaft reißt er
gesagt ich mache das von davon diese ich
bin ihn nicht schwarz und weiß
was ich sage wir könnten durchaus und
ich halte das wir durchaus nicht
unrealistisch dass ein lange zeit heißer
kalter regionaler kriege beginnt dass
wir nicht einfach jetzt sagen können
okay noch keine wird gelöst irgendwann
finden wir eine friedenslösung das reine
kommt der landtag und die will er wieder
wie verstehen sie ich bin bei ihnen dass
dieser krieg von wladimir putin den
ganzen globus erschüttert ich war vor
kurzem in singapur im shangri-la format
wo darüber diskutiert wurde auf der
anderen seite der erde mit australien
und neuseeland übrigens australien japan
länder die auch die ukraine unterstützen
obwohl es auf der anderen seite der
erdkugel ist also konkret waffen liefern
um wieder beim thema der saale westen
weil die freien westlichen staaten aber
auch nur die ja aber das ist doch eine
entscheidung was ist australien könnte
doch gut sagen leute auf der andern
seite der erdkugel macht euch mal locker
weil es um was ganz grundsätzlich ist
jetzt gerade geht und deswegen bin ich
der meinung ja das löst unglaubliche
fliehkräfte aus was wladimir putin macht
thema hungersnot selbst dass die türkei
ist wagt diese spielchen mit
griechenland zu machen was wirklich
unerträglich ist im luftraum
einzudringen inseln jena 47 zu
griechenland kam wieder lüstern dahin zu
gucken das ist alles unerträglich aber
ich finde dieser krieg um den weg ins um
den es jetzt gerade geht ist am 24
februar ausgebrochen weil die großen die
ukraine überfallen haben und ich hoffe
sehr dass bei aller diskussion bei allem
respekt vor anderen meinungen dass die
medien aber auch wir in der politik
dieses thema nicht unter den teppich
kehren nach dem motto es jetzt hat jetzt
schon ein bisschen lang nach dem motto
es gibt noch andere das versprechen das
hier gegeben an dem tisch ich verspreche
ist auch etwas was mich betrifft weil
das wäre das wäre das das vladimir putin
auf dauer will sie wissen es noch viel
besser als wir dass er den westen die
europäische union für weicheier gehalten
hat 27 staaten alle auf gleiche
augenhöhe nicht ganz unrecht sagt
professor pause wenn ich sie richtig
verstanden habe bisher mit ihrer
ängstlichkeit wir sind über ängstlich
ist es richtig damit spielt er ja auch
aber er will das hat der altkanzler
gesagt er will die eu zerstören oder
will die nato zerstörte er will in
europa eine russische dominanz
herstellen und das ist das entscheidende
das soll wenn es nicht gefallen dass das
wollte stalin 1945 lag aber völlig in
schutt und asche heute müssen wir uns
das nicht gefallen lassen aber wir
lassen uns das gefallen weil wir eben
noch zu viele zu viele europäische
staaten sind gut das bleibt auch so aber
der westen hat inzwischen eine
geschlossenheit ich finde ich ganz gut
wie die nato hat gesagt ihr
repräsentieren eine milliarde menschen
würde ich auch gut also und wir sind in
einem zweiten kalten krieg das müssen
wir uns jetzt mal wirklich vor augen
gehalten und wir wissen nicht mal sicher
ob dieser kalte krieg kalt bleiben wird
weil putin hat eine sozusagen die art
und weise dinge durchsetzen zu wollen
die er sich in den kopf gehen hat er bei
mir nicht so sicher ob sie da recht
haben mit dem kalten krieger wird so
diese beiden blöcke zumindest noch nicht
haben das ist man viele die sind
unentschieden oder besinnen sich erst
mal auf sich selbst martin hat glaube
ich damit gerechnet dass er sehr schnell
viele verbündete hat und auch damit hat
er sich verkalkuliert wer das geht ja
nicht um blöcke der kalte krieg war er
nicht an ein spiel von zwei blöcken
gegenüber es ist
die herausforderung der sowjetunion sie
wollte europa am besten ganz europa
beherrschen sie hat es nur bei osteuropa
geschafft hat sich der schauspieler im
block geschnitzt aber die block
konfrontation war nicht das wesentliche
des ost west konflikt so schließen wir
diese sendung ich danke ihnen der pause
dagegen frau strack-zimmermann herr
müller und ganz kurz herr fassbender in
die runde hat sich irgendjemand aus
sorge vor diesem herbst vor diesem
winter ein notstromaggregat schon
zugelegt würde sein
das ist der optimistische blick die
nächsten wochen und monaten wird dann
gegen das zuschauen hierbei gilt bis
nächsten sonntag
[Musik]